c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
une épaule
ce que j'imagine et ce que je crois
je te donne toutes mes différences tous
ces défauts qui sont autant de chance on
sera jamais des standards des gens bien
comme il faut
[Applaudissements]
je te donne ce que j'ai ce que je veux
c'est bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Aïcha
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme si je n'existais pas
elle est passée à côté de moi
sans un regard reine de Saba qu'est-ce
que j'ai dit
j'ai apprend tout est pour toi mais quoi
aussi
les perles les bijoux ah oui
au retour de ton cou
les fruits bien mûr au goût de miel
ma vie a échasé tu m'aimes voilà tout le
monde
[Musique]
c'est de la merde
[Applaudissements]
c'est parti c'est ma préférée
mettez bien le début allez-y Aurélie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aurélie n'a que 16 ans et elle attend un
enfant ses amis et ses parents lui
conseille là fortement elle n'est pas
d'accord elle voit les choses autrement
elle dit qu'elle se sent prête à qu'on
appelle maman celui-ci c'est pour toutes
les Obélix
pour toutes les Aurélie
mère à tout prix elle est en seconde
dans un lycée de banlieue dans son
quartier depuis il est comme Hélène
c'est-à-dire un peu plus vieux il a
l'air amoureux ils ont pour être heureux
il a jamais fait elle attendait juste le
bon gars elle se débrie dans la Twingo
donc ça va swinguer elle enlève son
temps
[Musique]
elle se retrouve seul dans cette
histoire
et elle attend un enfant ses amis et ses
parents lui conseilla avortement il
n'est pas d'accord elle doit les choses
autrement elle dit qu'elle se sent prête
pour qu'on l'appelle maman
elle se rappellera elle se rappellera le
jour où elle annonça ou elle annonça à
sa mère et son papa elle annonce à
qu'elle était enceinte de 3 mois elle
est là mais
elle va se retrouver
[Applaudissements]
c'est la meilleure
elle envoie du très très très très loin
qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autre
qu'est-ce que tu as les rois du monde
[Applaudissements]
c'est parti
[Musique]
les rois du monde
le sommet ils ont la plus belle plume et
la mer ils ne savent pas je comprends je
en bas il ne savent pas qui succède ou
les rois les mois du monde
qu'ils veulent et ils ont du monde
autour de mais ils sont seuls dans leur
château
là-haut il s'ennuie pendant qu'on va
tour dans toute la nuit nous on fait
l'amour au Villa des jours après jour
nuit après ça sert d'être sur la terre
si c'est pour faire nos vies on sait que
le temps c'est comme le temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça reste Aurélien
aurélie n'a que 16 ans
[Applaudissements]
début de soirée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du pareil au même moi je m'appelle
quand je rêve c'est Lola qui saigne mais
sur chaîne
[Applaudissements]
mais quand je donne ma langue je vois
[Musique]
c'est pas ma faute
si j'entends tout autour de moi et oui
[Applaudissements]
collégienne au bas le 2 mai
très bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chocolat
on y va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est une chanson
c'est de la fiction c'est de la fiction
ah un tabac qu'est-ce que vous voulez
les mecs quand il dit que on finira par
Goldman comme s'il y avait une voiture
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aimerais-tu que les patates elles se
sont montées
[Musique]
j'ai mal au cocotier
[Applaudissements]
j'adore j'adore
les gars vous voulez pas qu'on fasse des
10 chocolats
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Goldman c'est le son de l'année quand la
musique est bonne quand je me retourne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas cela mais non c'est je marche
seul
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment vas-tu
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
envoyer la petite ficelle
la vie
sur la tête les gars on va la refaire
dès que je suis comme un bateau délai
vous envoyer la pub bordel on la refait
soyez oh soyez percutant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu peux pas lâcher il faut pas la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va la faire tous ensemble
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je marche dans la vie
où la vie des pièges sur mes privilèges
je suis les jeux de Sam et ça ne
s'achète pas je m'en fous je m'en fous
que tu veux de cette chaîne qui parle
[Musique]
j'oublie je m'occupe parenthèse je suis
[Applaudissements]
dans les rues qui se tapent
et la nuit me pardonne je marche seul
en oubliant les heures je marche seul
[Musique]
je n'ai pas qui les hommes je marche
seul
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai rencontré séduit
quand l'inviter les chaînes j'ai besoin
d'être dans le premier pas les paroles
remettre sans le dire je crois que c'est
ça
les
[Applaudissements]
yeux qui dans la vie sauvetine en 16h
assassine je suis les jeux de Sam et ça
ne s'achète pas je m'en fous je m'en
fous de
tout de ces chaînes qui font des courses
je m'enfuis
j'oublie je m'appelle parenthèse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi merci les filles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Jacques Goldman
puisque tu pars
choisis la chanson que tu veux la
chanson que tu veux il y a encore
j'avais 20 ans
c'est un peu long Alexandre et Alexandra
un petit peu de François un peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non je ne sais plus comment faire
l'histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dites-lui que je porte comme elle que
j'aime toujours les chansons
qui parlent l'amour et dire aux fraises
cette version est pourrie on dirait
qu'elle est en Edge cette version
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Isabelle reviendrait demain
dans ce monde qui n'a plus d'espoir
la belle qui revient l'année prochaine
[Applaudissements]
de Daniel auront lieu le 4 juillet
à la cathédrale de Djerba
non mais c'est pratiquement la dernière
c'est la dernière donc allez-y donc elle
avait choisi Joe Dassin ça y est on l'a
fait choisi un truc toi tu veux dire un
truc pas une merde manger
laquelle
[Musique]
Il avait les mots elle est géniale pas
du tout vous allez voir
ça fait beaucoup de force cette chanson
[Musique]
que moi je suis tout bêtement
tombé dans ses bras
parmi j'ai découvert ce que je
connaissais pas il semblait sincère je
l'aimais pour ça
ce qui m'a toujours dérangé c'est que ma
mousse il faut faire depuis maintenant
il avait les mots
marrant tu vas trop je ne t'ai déjà
l'avenir dans ses bras il avait les mots
m'a rendu accro
vous imaginez la même chanson que Daniel
Moreau lâche qu'il aurait le mec
un truc comme ça
en fait toutes les occasions sont bonnes
pour me chier pour moi arrête arrête je
voulais juste vous faire plaisir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un truc comme ça
[Applaudissements]
mexicain
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quoi
le mec qui cherche son ocarina il
cherche
[Rires]
je te le dis sans faire reste cool bébé
sinon je te dirai Bye Bye
[Musique]
les mecs les mecs c'est quoi cette
version
vous avez mis une version
on l'a fait vas-y
bébé sinon je te dirai Bye Bye
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de neige bien je n'ai pas vu l'heure
qu'il était ah ouais c'est vrai
savoir pourquoi tu agis comme un voleur
[Musique]
à toi tu joues
avec des lacets
[Applaudissements]
au téléphone
[Musique]
reste cool bébé sinon je te dirai pas
bye tu es Descelles qui je te le dis
sans ça
[Applaudissements]
tu es la seule qui m'aille je te le dis
sans faille reste cool bébé sinon je te
dirait pas
ah ouais
bravo
merci
[Rires]
qu'est-ce que tu veux Valérie c'est pour
toi ma chérie un truc tout les deux non
enfin d'accord non
non je veux pas
une chanson
moi je cherche une chanson tu sais on
peut où on se bouffe un peu le cul ou tu
vois
mais j'arrive pas il y a rien qui
m'inspire pas même si tu la trouves on
la fera pas
je suis
emmerde pas cher
[Applaudissements]
je peux pas faire briter sans perruque
je veux des perruques je veux des choses
on est là
alors ça c'est pas Britney distributeur
c'est c'est Dave
moi je vais faire Britney café
c'est quoi cette chanson
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la perruque est très bien
[Applaudissements]
je prends donc je pars avec un café
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jamais entendu parler
au quotidien c'est la misère et la
guerre j'ai trouvé
on peut synchronismes que ça ne dites
mais pourtant pulvériser
é
la violence éternelle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pense qu'il faut que vous mettiez des
sons et en fait il faut tout ce que je
les fasse façon Renault
[Musique]
tu vois tu veux du Joe Dassin encore
on peut changer allez-y vous demandez ce
que vous voulez j'ai de la perruque j'ai
tout ce que vous publiez que c'est fini
et mon ouvrier
Lavoine le chanteur
Jeanne Mas toute première fois
pour Daniel tu apprends de l'argent
c'est qui ça
[Musique]
ça va être encore mieux
au vent
des Landes de pierre autour
des lacs c'est pour
les vivants
un peu
d'enfer le Connemara
[Musique]
qui viennent du nord
colore la terre les lacs les rivière
c'est le décor tu connais ma part
je t'ai dit c'est dit je suis catholique
[Musique]
sont arrivés dans le comté du Connemara
on sait tout le prix du silence
[Musique]
là haut que les
je veux la vie c'est une folie mais que
la folie s'adapte danse merci merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
en mémoire si tu me survis d'être plus
fort que jamais je serai toujours dans
ta vie
fais-toi
je te promets et si la mort nous c'est
grave sur son grand ordinateur
de ne pas en faire un drame de ne pas
s'en avoir faim pense à moi quand je
t'aime
et tu me délivrera
alors on a fait une dernière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que ça peut être là
ça fait comme une éclipse une nuit plein
d'étoiles sur le port de Tunis
le vent de l'éventail de ton grand-père
assis au café des délices
des souvenirs se voilent tu la revois
la blancheur des voiles des femmes tuent
un fils
[Musique]
les odeurs du jasmin qu'il tenait danser
au café des délices attention tout le
monde
[Musique]
y aller y aller
y aller
souvenirs
[Musique]
les noyaux d'abricots pour toi c'était
des billes
et les soirées de fait qu'on faisait
dans nos têtes au clash de ma mère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va en faire une dernière il va
falloir bien choisir trop de alors
regarde l'intro de alors regarde pas mal
non
pas moi tu arrêtes depuis longtemps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais ne viens pas quand je serai seul
[Applaudissements]
je veux qu'il tombe derrière moi
[Musique]
mais ne viens pas quand je serai seul
moi prier tout choisi dans ma vie je
veux choisir ma mort aussi et ma soeur
qui va le mourir un jour de pluie et
d'autres en place soleil
et la seule qui l'a mourir seul dans
un tranquillement
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je sais
dans le
coque pour
[Applaudissements]
les autres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très très fort Dalida est très fort elle
est très forte Dalila
allumer le feu
je sais pas je sais pas faut terminer
par un truc de ouf là ouais
je vais mettre la perruque et vous allez
choisir ok vas-y non dites-moi ce que
vous voulez ressemblera tout le monde là
Johnny Johnny
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je te promets
[Applaudissements]
le truc de ouf
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en fait la meilleure c'est bon
[Musique]
ARDS
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Auchan depuis le début et j'ai une
demande pendant la pause d'une personne
qui voudrait chanter avec moi la chanson
qui aime qui a été le son de l'année
pour nous c'est quand même cliché
il y a une personne qui veut la chanter
avec moi c'est mon fils
il est là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu es la plus belle des étoiles parmi
les autres je vois que toi si tu te
rends compte dis-moi il me reste une
place près de moi le projecteur surprend
chez vous comment tu brilles dans le
noir
[Musique]
mais entre nous je peux pas dire ce qui
s'est passé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi qu'est-ce que j'ai fait bon
qu'est-ce que je fais bon sang
mais il y a qu'à toi tu peux me confier
[Applaudissements]
papa
[Musique]
qui s'est passé je pense à toi chaque
jour j'aimerais connaître
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
[Applaudissements]